mg show you can be intentional about
your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's
the dave ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice dr john
dolone ramsey personality and
best-selling author of the book
redefining anxiety
is my co-host today he's answering your
questions about your life i'll answer
your questions about your money and
we'll probably both
answer your questions anyway open phones
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five james starts off this
hour in tampa florida hi james welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hey dave and dr d how are you guys great
man how can we help
so my question for you guys today is
i am planning on proposing to my
girlfriend
uh in the coming year congratulations
and
i appreciate that really excited we've
been together for about
three just over three years now um
and so yeah just ready to take that next
step forward i started looking at rings
and things like that
and my question though is so i
i am debt free but she has quite a bit
of debt and so i'm trying to figure out
how to start planning for that after
you know we get engaged we get married
combined bank accounts and all that
stuff
uh how do i plan to tackle per day for
basically going back from baby step
four to baby step two well that's
exactly what you'll do
uh whatever money you have in savings
when you come home from the honeymoon
you will throw it at
the debt snowball and then the two of
you will combine your households
your incomes and uh you're you know
you're going to work her debt off then
the two of you
and so how much debt has she got
uh it's probably going to be around six
i
guess 55 to 60 000 okay
and what's her attitude about all that
uh well it's funny you asked that i've
been trying to
to ease this conversation in with her
um and trying to talk about or kind of
have that dream conversation that you
guys talk about a lot and haven't
had that conversation yet um but she's
on board with it but she
she does not believe that i said we can
do it in less than five years
and i told her i said okay well you know
jump on board with me
and you know but we'll do it under five
years i can promise you that
and she doesn't believe me well wait a
minute what is your what is your income
so my i make about fifty thousand
dollars with commission
so this year will probably be around 65.
what's she making she's a nurse
she's a nurse probably makes 50 to 55
000.
okay so here's a simple thing that a
nurse can do anybody can do
okay is you make a hundred thousand
if you put if you put thirty thousand
out of a hundred on your debt you're
debt-free in two years
exactly that's exactly my point and if
she if
i mean if you have that if you say that
sentence
and she rolls her eyes then you've got a
problem
right and i think i i i'm wondering
how you've been with somebody for three
and a half years and you're still
and you're about to buy an engagement
ring and you're still tiptoeing around
any conversation
like there you don't tiptoe around a
dreaming conversation brother you've
been together for three and a half
years like what is stopping you from
sitting down and
having that that should be a point of
joy and a point of coming together not
some sort of apprehensive moment why are
you waiting to have that conversation
i really don't have uh a reason i just i
i just haven't done it to be completely
honest give her that gift
that's a gift to any prospective spouse
male or female for the other person to
sit down and say i want to dream
together with you
that's awesome man that's a good place
and as dave said this is a math problem
and another thing a nurse can do
especially in this universe
is work saturdays for another nine
months
and make a whole bunch extra money and
you can do something on the side and you
all can take that
to two years and cut it down to 18
months
or maybe even 15 months if you all get
bananas about it
i left out how much have you got in
savings
i've got about 45 000. okay
and she has 50 and she has 55 000
in debt uh so if you write a check for
45 000 there's only 10 000 left right
okay well after you're married and uh
you're making a hundred thousand
so you should be debt-free in like two
months
this is the greatest call of your life
brother we've just solved all of your
problems
and then you're gonna rebuild your
savings and she can't be nervous about
using up your savings because she's not
got any savings
so she's already should be nervous right
yes completely agreed and you brother
are gonna have to work on the pronoun
problem
which is this is gonna quickly become
not her
debt but y'all's debt our debt our debt
our income your savings our savings
account our savings that's right
yeah when you are married and come home
from the honeymoon the pronouns change
you are now french we we
we do stuff now we do stuff together
that's right
it's not your stuff my stuff it's uh
unless the dog goes on the floor and
then it's your dog
other than that it's everything else
right
but uh oh my gosh that's your child
that's misbehaving that's right that's
right
that is your son that's actually a rule
my wife and i have
yeah whichever whichever he's standing
in the military peeing he's your son
whichever behavior the the principal
calls us on
that person's got to go to the god john
i'm
that's right i agree with her on that
part but yeah now change your pronouns
as soon as you get married and you can
say what and you could even do that in
the dream meeting and say
what how is life going to look like for
us right we what is it we're going to do
and what if we took after marriage and
applied 45 000 to 55
000 worth of debt and in the meantime
you work like crazy and you've already
paid it down
10 from working weekends and so when we
come home from the honeymoon we're like
debt-free
how cool is that that would be a dream
that's better than five years five years
kind of sucks
yeah and your life right now kind of
sucks so
maybe we can fix this thing i think we
got a bad dream
not a bad dream we're gonna put
financial coaches and counselors out of
business
if we solve people's marriages like that
man now well i mean sharon and i were on
about our third date i was driving a
monte carlo with 285 000 miles on it
third engine second transmission i was
gonna say that's back when
yeah it was i mean i had driven this car
i i it was on its third life
and i was explaining to her i had a
dollar sixteen in my checking account
and i was explaining to her how some day
i was gonna be a millionaire and about
that time we went across the railroad
tracks and muffler fell off my car
so this is this is this dream meeting
right the dream this is the dream
meeting what could this look like
and uh and you know the strange part is
the woman actually believed me
hey and she was right that's right
because i'm so dumb i've done it twice
there you go a millionaire twice two
different times now
oh my gosh yeah that's that's that's the
dream meeting that's what you're doing
and it's okay if the muffler falls off
the car in the middle of the dream
meeting
but just uh have it and sit down and
change your pronouns and start laying
out some math plans and start talking
about going through
maybe you go through ramsey plus during
this year uh while you're planning and
getting married and
finish up and revisit after the marriage
and that kind of stuff you'd have a
whole
year lined out to do all that very cool
man very cool
[Music]
[Applause]
open phones at 825-5225
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author of the book
redefining
anxiety what it is what it's not and how
to get your life back
we're taking your questions about your
life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five jake is in san francisco hi
jake how are you
hey i'm doing good dave hey thank you um
my question is all right i just sold
a rental property and i'll close next
week and i'll be
debt-free for the first time in my life
all right and
uh yeah i'm excited um
i uh i just sold this property many
clothes i'm gonna have about a half a
million
um cash to uh put and i'm
i'm thinking of putting it just into
retirement into mutual funds and
uh i have about 275
or more in mutuals right now
so it'll give me about maybe close to
800
and my home is free and clear and it's
worth about a million and i have a
rental in newport
um that's about a million five and
they're both free and clear paid for
way to go man you've killed it
congratulations
thank you thank you yeah i'm i'm uh
i'm real happy about that and thank you
i've been on your
leadership team for financial peace
several times
and love that program and
anyway so i'm trying to figure out um
when i do this is that if i put it into
the
mutual funds right now i'm i'm in
basically three
um it's a blue chip growth fund
and then the s p index and then
a balanced fund that's about thirty
percent bonds
and i think the blue chips up about 52
this year and the s p i think is
probably around 15 now and the balance
is about
13. so i'm thinking about splitting that
money and putting in there um i'm a
little nervous because i've been in real
estate my whole life and
i sell it as an agent and i'm retired
now
and uh so i'm just trying to figure out
um whether that's a good move to split
it like the rest of the stuff i have
into those three in mutual funds and
jake you got you got three four million
dollars um i think you're not gonna mess
this up
so spreading it across those three is
probably all right
um i i you could do that i have my
mutual funds across
four types growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international
i'm not big on bonds because they
haven't kept up with
equities in terms of long-term track
record and performance
i'm not a fan uh i'm 60 years old i
don't have a diamond bonds
um just to give you an idea so i'm 70
i'm 76 right now so you're not going to
use this money
somebody else is see what i can do to
spend it
yeah i mean you can take a run at it but
you're gonna have to get pretty crazy
man
to go through all this but yeah so you
can do that here's the thing i think
you're looking for i think you sit down
with a smartvestor pro
clickdavramsey.com
click smart investor and sit down with
an advisor that and here's what i want
you to ask them about
look at some what's called low turnover
mutual funds one place you can always
find low turnover is with an
s p 500 fund an index fund low turnover
simply means they don't sell the stocks
inside the funds very often almost
always it's a buy hold
strategy the turnover rate is five
percent or less
therefore all of your growth is going to
be capital gains growth or almost all of
it is going to be capital gains growth
so you don't need taxes on the growth
until you cash it out and when you do
cash it out if it's been in there longer
than a year
it's going to be taxed at the at a
capital gains rate not an ordinary
income rate so 15
instead of whatever your tax rate is 30
or 35 percent
and so uh i personally do a lot of low
turnover mutual funds i'll throw money
into an s
p 500 and just let it sit there two or
three years and then go buy a piece of
real estate
with whatever it grows to that's what i
do with it but if it just sits there
the point being that if you buy a share
of stock for 50 and it goes up to 70
you do not pay taxes on the 20 gain
until you sell the stock right
right and so it's growing like real
estate does with a uh
you're getting a tax deferred growth
you don't have to pay taxes on the
growth until you cash in
and so the low turnover mutual fund
keeps you from having to pay taxes
every year on the growth where like if
you buy a high turnover mutual fund
like for instance an aggressive growth
stock mutual fund a lot of times they'll
have like a
not a five percent turnover but they may
have a 200 turnover they may turn the
whole thing over twice in a year
which means every bit of gain that that
thing has is taxable that year
and not taxable at capital gains rate
cap taxable at your ordinary income rate
which is at least double of otherwise so
you're paying twice as much taxes and
you're paying them
on and you're paying them every year
rather than letting it
letting the tax money grow more money
for you
by letting it sit in there so you have
to pay taxes on
growth on the gain before you even cash
it out
on a mutual fund you do if they have
cashed it out inside the mutual fund
okay so like a mutual fund have 90 to
200 stocks in it
and if they're selling every time they
sell one of those stocks whatever that
stock has gone up in value that amount
is going to be taxable for you that year
even if you're not holding the cash in
hand even if you are have not cashed in
they cashed in inside the fund so you
could conceivably pay cash
or pay taxes on a mutual fund year over
year
that ends up losing money someday and
you've paid taxes against something that
went away huh yep without holding that
money in hand yeah huh
it's you know if you buy a share of home
depot stock and i don't even know what
it goes for i'm just making this up and
it goes from 50
to 70 and you sell it you're right
you're gonna pay taxes on that 20 bucks
on that 20
right but you're not if you hold it okay
until you sell it
and if you hold it longer than one year
it's only taxed at 15
there you go so multiply that times 90
to 200 inside of a mutual fund and
that's what's going on all those things
spinning out or not spinning out gotcha
so as long as they're sitting there and
they're not selling them and a 95
hold rate is considered a 5 turnover
rate is considered a low
turnover or no turnover mutual fund and
almost all your s p
500s are that because they're just
trying to model the 500 okay they're
buying them and just keeping them okay
and that's one place you can find them
but you can also find other mutual funds
that have a low turnover rate in them
but that's what i would look for if i
were in that mix
um and i know i would look for because
this is what i freaking do it's what you
do right yeah
so because i do anything i can to be tax
efficient
and get a good rate of return and it's
one of the reasons i buy so much real
estate
is i buy it it goes up in value i don't
pay taxes on the growth
and value my net worth goes way up and i
don't
i don't have the cash in my pocket right
when a a piece of property goes from 100
000 to 150 000 in value
i don't have that 50 000 in cash but i
do have that value there
right and i can get to it if i wanted to
sell it
but i don't so that's right
uh open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
joshua is in knoxville hey joshua how
are you
hey dave and dr dolani how are you all
great man what's up
um i've been in business for about eight
years and i'm wondering if i should go
ahead and build a warehouse for my
business
what's the growth curve on your business
uh i've been up about 15 percent
every year besides for this year i'm
down about 30 percent do the
surrounding buyers if we didn't have the
pandemic
in the last five years your business has
tripled
uh yes pretty close so when you build a
warehouse are you going to build it for
five years from now three times as big
um i'm hoping to go are you gonna have
to move out of your own warehouse
well right now i currently rent and i've
got about 2 000 square feet i was
wanting to build around
3 500. yeah you see my point is you're
going to be out of that thing in two and
a half years
right right because your growth is going
to take
you know right now i've got quite a bit
of room it's more of getting more orders
in really
you know yeah than okay here here's let
me let me give you the brief synopsis on
real estate
as you know i love real estate so your
brief synopsis is this your business is
growing so fast
that if you're not careful you're going
to own a piece of real estate and you're
going to go oh i don't want to move
because i own this now the real estate
is wagging the businesses to the
business wagging the real estate the
dog's wagging the tail
rather than the tail wagging the dog or
basketball i got that backwards but
anyway you see what i'm saying i bought
a piece of real estate
and i it became me
keeping the company in the real estate
started to mess up the company
i started trying to take care of the
real estate instead of trying to take
care of the company
and so the only way it's going to work
is if you buy a big piece of buy
a bigger warehouse so that you can stay
there a while
and then when you do move you need a
marketable warehouse that you can sell
it or
rent it out when you do move out of it
because that's what we did with our old
building
we had to move out of it we outgrew it
like three times over
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com will help you every step of
the way
just like they've helped thousands of my
listeners
with free design help by phone and
online
plus they guarantee the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
[Music]
doctor tony dr joney dr john
uh that's his name he's my co-host i
like doctor joni
and dr chachi in germany chachi
oh my gosh open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five on the debt free stage
in the ramsey solutions lobby tyler and
jessica
are with us hey guys how are you hey
good how are you
better than i deserve welcome it's good
to have you where do you guys live
des moines iowa ah and all the way to
nashville
so how much debt did you two pay off 282
952.26 goodness
how long did this take 23 months
and your range of income during this 23
months
84 000 to 135 000.
okay and what do y'all do for a living i
am a middle school counselor and i'm in
sales
okay cool okay so you did not make 283
000 during that period of time which
tells me you must have sold something we
sold our house
all right what'd your house bring uh we
sold it for 140 000.
okay um we were moving so
anyway yeah so uh when it sold that paid
off
some the mortgage debt yeah obviously so
you're renting now
we we we now have bought a house oh
since then
yes okay yeah and um what was the rest
of the debt the other 140
sallie mae all shelley
10 000 was a car loan but oh my god
you threw it out there as though that's
better like uh
all sallie mae yeah
so what happened 23 months ago they got
you guys on fire
we well we decided we wanted to move
closer to family i took a new job and
we decided with the house we had we
weren't getting anywhere
with our loans we were doing davish we
decided to go
all in this is the perfect time and we
sold our house
we put everything we made from the house
into our student loans
and just went after it from there okay
all right and then after that you were
able to save up a down payment and buy
later
yes okay all right way to go you guys
wow i mean that just that took off so
what i mean
when you made the decision to move what
made you decide to to
uh say okay while we're moving we might
as well
clean up this mess yeah there's a couple
things
we were looking at houses and where we
were moving the houses were more
expensive so we decided to wait
and we have a little one at home aurora
so
when we found out we were pregnant we're
like let's get it done
and we were going to change her life hey
man so we got more jobs
yes more and more jobs lots of work lots
of work
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
uh if you have a spouse communicate
be okay with telling each other no
respect each other enough to tell each
other no so you can
can get it done i remember we would sit
there and ask each other to buy stuff
and
we just asked a question does this align
with our goals
and if it didn't we didn't buy it so we
literally did nothing
[Laughter]
for 23 months you had no life correct
basically and now and now you're free
and powerful you live like no one else
so now you can live and give like no one
else yeah
yeah and aurora has a whole different
future because of you
yeah it's amazing how old are you two
i'm 33
32. wow you're impressive i was gonna
say
yeah i would have thought y'all are 25
and 26 is
i wish beautiful and as light as you
feel right
how old is aurora now she's gonna be 10
months next week
and so how much of this stress do you
feel like she internalized versus
what she's going to be able to live with
without um
you know that was one of my biggest
things is i didn't want to live
in a rental and now i'm thinking she's
never going to remember
any of this right and we get to tell her
this wonderful story someday
and she's never going to have to
live like we did before so back in all
18
yeah your mom and paul who came to who
was the idea
well we his brother my brother's been
doing it
my he was finan he's out of debt my
sister did it
um so it's kind of started with my
family but our support group with both
of our families
um i've known of it and that's why we've
been doing
dave ish for a long time and we decided
this is enough
let's get it done so there was no big
you're a salesman for a living so there
was no big sales job here it was
as much as a of a math problem and yeah
yeah i honestly didn't i mean he
told me about it when we were you know
going out and in college and i was like
man that doesn't seem like
that'll ever happen i have over a
hundred thousand dollars in
student loans and i remember the day we
sat down at the table
and finally wrote out all of our loans
and i just cried
and i thought that moment would never
end and
i just can't believe we're here i can't
believe you did it happened
you did it you're heroes you're complete
heroes you completely stole the day
i'm so proud of y'all thank you thank
you very well done
very well done who are your biggest
cheerleaders
our family and then his brother and
sister yeah his brothers he's
in the middle of this story for sure
they just kept telling us
to to keep going when we didn't want to
and
keep living and where we were living and
couldn't have done it without them our
family i mean especially mine and
and hers as well we got so intense
christmas we were like
no gifts so and it was cool because
because they got it and they they
supported us so
that's very cool well congratulations
thank you after all of this
how's it feel it feels amazing
amazing it feels freeing you can see it
on their faces it's just you can see it
through the glass they're just
like right there light bulbs right there
yeah cool well done
well done all right tyler and jessica
des moines iowa 283
thousand dollars paid off in 23 months
making 84 to 135. we've got a copy of
chris hogan's book for you everyday
millionaires
that's the next chapter in your story
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one we're different
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah baby i love it well done
well done well done that's so cool every
time
never gets old today's the last day to
enter our ramsey
christmas cash giveaway could be your
chance to win
our grand prize of five thousand dollars
now that would make christmas special
wouldn't it
enter daily to increase your chances of
winning today's the last day so it's not
daily
it's today and uh go to daveramsey.com
giveaway our team is using every reason
to give stuff away you can now pick up
our life-changing books
for about 90 off during our week-long
green monday sale get books like the
number one bestseller is the total money
makeover dr
john deloney's new best seller it's a
quick read redefining anxiety
all these are only 10 bucks and
redefining anxiety
is selling white hot going crazy
yeah these are exactly what every
household needs to make a plan and get
control
enter to win a chance to win at the 5
000
and get some deals all at daveramsey.com
today is
the last day to enter we will be
announcing
the winner coming up of the five
thousand dollars in the next few days
so you don't want to miss that and you
don't want to miss your chance to
get registered and take a shot at five
grand five grand a lot
i would i've registered myself for i i'm
just kidding
they would do no good that's exactly
right but i thought you always violate
the rules and then if we drew your name
we would not
say oh look john won we would say what
is john
doing and he's fired right so no it's 5
000 bucks is awesome man
5 000 bucks is awesome and it's cool to
be thinking about gifts that are
actually gonna
be something other than a plastic toy
that's gonna end up in a in a bin
somewhere
or some knuckleheaded something or other
get something that's actually gonna help
somebody's life when we were kids
my mom and i were in the real estate
business and we moved so much that we
had we just kept all the boxes that were
labeled
and we had two boxes that never got
unpacked
seldom used kitchen items but we're
going to keep them but we're going to
keep them they're seldom used yes
and you know we bought a bunch of crap
in our culture that is of no value
none so don't buy them a seldom use
kitchen item buy them a dr john dolone
book and it'll change their life
it's actually usable they will not go
into the box
they're just selling them not going into
the box nothing will not say seldom
this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
so
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five devin is in denver hi devon
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave how you doing better than i
deserve how can i help
so my wife and i we started your program
at the beginning
of this year we're currently on baby
steps
um number two we've paid off a little
over 20 000
uh so far and we got right at 19 to go
um aside from our house but my question
to you is
um my wife is currently expecting yay
and
uh yay woo hoo cool for us right yeah
so but we know we're gonna have to pay
a 7 000 deductible next year
to march uh because of the way that our
interest is
set up so i'm curious do we keep slaving
away on this debt snowball
or do we stop and start saving up for
the seven thousand dollars
that we inevitably know we're gonna owe
in march
you got you got really good instincts
devin yeah you you stop
your baby steps you push pause on your
total money makeover baby steps okay
and you save up as much as you can save
up
between now and the time baby comes
whatever the expenses are out of pocket
that you have to cover like the seven
thousand dollars obviously you need to
cover that but i'd love for you to save
even more
i mean what if you save seventeen
thousand dollars okay
and uh you know mom and baby come home
baby comes mama baby come home from the
hospital everybody's safe everybody's
good
um and uh you write a check and you pay
off the seven thousand dollar deductible
and you have ten thousand dollars left
you push play on your baby steps again
your debt snowball is where you are and
so you would take the ten thousand
dollars out of that account back down to
one thousand dollars and you throw it at
your smallest debt and game on again
and you lost very little traction on
your overall plan
except your deductible in the story i
just told
perfect yeah sounds like a game plan
yeah
congratulations man that's awesome good
for you man yeah i'm proud of you
good stuff open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five james is with us in
redmond california
hi james how are you i am focused
certainly not finished uh dave dr john
how the heck
are you man we're doing good today how
can we help
awesome um i have a question about baby
step
four i am not there yet i'm in baby step
two so i am not contributing to my
retirement yet
um my company offers a very juicy match
that i
intend to take advantage of when i get
there good the
um yes i had a question about
about this because they only offer a
traditional
401k vehicle for that retirement and not
ross
and i i get the logic i get the logic
and totally agree with you on
roth contributions so how do i take
advantage of the match
when the company doesn't offer a 401k
through you know through the service or
vanguard in this case
right they don't have a roth option
doesn't matter you still take the match
but i wouldn't take any more than the
match so how much is the match what
percentages
um so it starts uh it starts at uh at
eight percent
uh and then after three years of service
to the company it jumps to ten
okay so you have to put in eight or ten
to get them to match the eight or ten
they they match up to i i have to
look exactly how it works but but they
match up to 10
of your eligible pays if i recall
correctly
but do you have to put in that 10 for
them to match
i yes yes i believe so okay so you're
going to put
let's just call it 10. let's say you're
putting 10
into a traditional but you have a 100
percent rate of return the instant you
do that because they're going to put in
another 10.
there's no mutual funds that pay 100
rate of return so that's why you always
do the match
right then i would stop and for the
other five percent to get you up to
fifteen percent
i would jump over and do a trade a
personal
roth ira in good mutual funds
now what is your income uh so
my job currently uh pays me 57 but i'm
i'm doing gazelle intense so i'm also
doing mortgages
uh and uh delivery so i think
my income will probably be at about 120.
okay then five percent is going to be
about six thousand dollars which is a
roth ira oddly enough
right and so if you do if you make if
you make 150
then you're gonna go on to the third
step and because you can you know you
can only put six thousand in your roth
and uh and you've got your ten percent
match but you still need to put more in
to something and you've run out of roth
options and run out of
match options so now you go to the third
option which is just a traditional
so that means you're going to end up
putting more than 10 if you make more
than 120
into uh you might put 11 or even uh
you know 11 whatever it ends up being to
get you to the actual dollar amounts
that
equate to 15 of your income
and so that's very good and don't forget
to hold the taxes out
on your side hustles if they're not
being done already too
that's a good point they'll sneak up on
you because you can get to where you're
capturing that
that 1099 will cross you in the head
that's right yeah you get that puppy in
because i mean it sounds like he's
making some serious bank and if your
mortgage brokering in their 1099 you're
contracting that
as well then more than half your income
you got no taxes coming out that's right
and that's a good call suddenly you look
at that big mega number and it says 120
150 it feels so
good but it's not that much right yeah
well i mean you do need to do the 15
calculation on the on the gross number
right but
yeah you better be setting those taxes
back in addition to what we're talking
about
so really cool man you're hustling
you're hustling yeah good for you
get after it lyle is in meridian
idaho hi lyle how are you
i'm doing good dave how are you better
than i deserve what's up
so um i just had a question for you
because
um i i'm a graduate student um
here in idaho um i did the thing that
every financial penny pincher would have
a heart attack over i i went to medical
school or i'm in medical school
and uh but before i was accepted to
medical school
i did door-to-door sales as an
undergraduate
and i made a good chunk of money and i
put some money in an investment
towards a like a a part ownership of an
airbnb
in nashville and i just kind of wanted
to
hear your thoughts on that it the hope
of investing in the
um the nashville property was to have
you know some residual income
every quarter and we were my wife and i
are planning was to take that residual
income and
you know put it mainly the main focus
was to put it towards our daughter's
future
we have a two-year-old baby girl and um
but since covet has said
mayor kind of messed up your little b
and b thing didn't he
yeah it did but i mean the first year we
had it we bought it in 2018.
yep that's right yeah
yeah yeah sell it yeah so
yeah so i mean sell it it was working oh
sell it
sell it you live in freaking idaho
it's in nashville dude you are spread
so thin you have your you have so many
things are garnering for your attention
and you're going to do none of them well
right you need to concentrate on med
school getting through it and paying
cash
and use that airbnb to do it you got too
many balls in the air you're juggling
arrows one of them's gonna stick you in
the eye
get rid of that thing and it's that
nashville property is what it is
and and yeah so just let me yeah you're
right every financial penny pincher
in america that would be me i'm the king
of them
i am the king freaking penny pincher i'm
not cringing about you going to mexico
i'm cringing about you
going into debt to buy a property
entirely across the continent
for airbnb in a city where the mayor
shut down the whole economy
the only city in tennessee where that
has happened by the way
so and i've got friends who are doctors
whose kids are in college
and they're paying off their student
loans still
and so when you're borrowing money to go
to med school and you're
borrowing money to buy an investment
property so that your daughter that's
just
priorities are out of whack yeah too
many things going on too many things
yeah the best thing you can do for your
daughter's future is get through med
school
debt-free and or pay that debt off asap
one of the two and you cast cash flow
her life trying to
borrow your way into wealth
it's not the shortest method
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's
the dave ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i am dave
ramsey your host
dr john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author of the book
redefining anxiety is my co-host
today here on the air we're taking your
calls about your life
your money and certainly with dr d here
we'll talk about your life
uh anything that's going on with you
we're here to help you open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five mike is with us
mike is in oklahoma city hey mike
welcome to the dave ramsey show
thank you dan how are you doing sure man
what's up
yeah my uh my father passed away from
closing back on the night
oh no and yeah it's been kind of rough
for us
my mother inherited his 401k
and it's been his it's in his group plan
um they informed her she could keep it
in there
she retired he set free we don't
i don't we don't know what to do can we
roll it over
they did tell her that uh it would no
longer be managed by the asset group
and neither one of us or has any extra
and in investing so i'm so sorry
how old was your dad 69
that sounds younger every day um
okay uh how much is in the 401k
it's 720 000. okay
720 000 yes
okay well this is um he also has a
tension
in life that all of this is gonna be
coming in and we
have nobody to think we just kind of
figure out where we need to go
yeah we know we just no we don't want to
touch him yeah we want it to grow
right and does your mom have an income
other than from this money that that she
can live on or do we need to draw some
off of this to for her to live
she she uh she received her social
security i think it's like
two thousand one hundred and something
dollars a month and that's plenty
uh for her uh like i said the house has
paid off
the first paid off he left in really
good shape and they were debt free
they worked themselves though yeah out
of that well she needs to get more than
two thousand dollars a month man
i mean we need to we need to give her a
better life than that because she's a
millionaire
she is so tight i know but she needs to
lighten up and enjoy a little bit of it
and she does not have to go hog wild and
lose
200 000 at the craps table or something
like that but she ought to
she ought to go and do some stuff and
buy some stuff
here or there and so i i would have you
draw a couple thousand dollars
additional off of this money a month
that's 24 000 a year that won't even
touch it
there's no possible way she could go
through this money in her lifetime
doing that but it would double her
quality of life and so let's do that for
mom
so what you need to do here's what
you're looking for
you are not and here's what you're not
looking for you are not looking for
a money manager an investment broker
who tells you what to do and you just go
along with whatever he or she says
because they have letters after their
name and a nice suit
this is how you lose all your money do
not do that
okay what you are looking for is an
investment
advisor that will teach you
and mom and it may take a little bit of
effort
and it may be difficult during this time
of grieving
so it's okay if you don't do anything
fancy at first
so here's here's a couple of steps for
you that i would tell you to do
number one let's don't get in a hurry
on becoming an investment expert
you're not going to be one in 20 minutes
okay okay
let yourself off the hook but also don't
just turn it over to somebody because
they're smart and you think you're dumb
that's how people lose all their money
like those athletes that lost all their
money that's what they did
and that was one of the anxiety points
for me to trust somebody like that yeah
you don't do that it's not their money
it's your mom's money
you trust you and your mom okay and the
way you can trust you is you're gonna
learn so here's some steps that
allow you to move slowly and carefully
so rule number ones don't go fast rule
number two is don't invest money and
anything you don't understand which
means you can't go fast because it's
going to take you a while to understand
okay okay that's okay no shame in that
at all
first time you drove the car you don't
need to drive it fast that's all right
right yes yes put the tractor in the
backfield let the bush hog down and put
it in granny gear and turn them loose
right
you can't mess nothing up you know what
i'm saying absolutely
just go slow all right now so go to
daveramsey.com click on smart investor
pro
put in the information it'll drop down a
list of the pros in your area
you can interview as many of them as you
want and then you select the one that
you like the best and your mom likes the
best
and go with the way your mom she needs
to
use words like i like that guy
he feels safe
the way the way her spirit reacts to the
person
is going to be a really good indicator
does that make sense
yes yes it does and that's not so that
you trust them to do stuff blindly
it's you trust them to teach you the
last step after go
slow and don't put money in anything you
don't understand the last step is
with all financial people especially in
a situation like this where you feel
inept
because you are you are looking not for
a salesperson you are looking for
a teacher they have to have the heart of
a teacher
and you will know you have met with a
teacher if after you leave their office
you have learned something
now i would suggest that you roll this
401k
and the pension into a simple money
market
account with a smart investor pro that's
just a savings account like a bank
it's going to pay almost nothing like
one percent they suck
but they're a hundred percent safe and
it's just like opening a bank account
you can do that you already understand
that
right then park your emotions and give
you mom a little time to grieve
this is really fresh gosh it is
and then have another meeting with the
smartvestor pro and another meeting with
the smartmister pro in another meeting
with smartvister pro
and sometime around september you will a
have
learned enough and b have given yourself
time to cry enough
that your brain is no longer in a fog
and you can begin the investing process
and moving some of it into mutual funds
okay
gotcha but you need to learn about it
and you need to have a clear mind and
no one lose it your mom and dad were
married a long time
yes and he was a good provider he cared
for him yeah cared for you guys
yeah and you know it it's just your your
brain your mama's
brain for sure yours too but your mama's
even more so is in a fog of grief right
now and that's not when you make 700 000
decisions
you just put in a savings account over
at that smart vista pro get out of that
company
get away from them just park it there
give yourself time to breathe
john yeah and and make sure most
sons want to go in and fix everything
that's the way they're going to honor
their dad i want you to also make sure
you take time to grieve too
make sure you've got some buddies you
can talk to make sure you've got some
people in your life that you can sit
down and just say
i miss my old man and this sucks and
that you can cry as well
yeah okay yeah yeah i'm so sorry you
guys are going through this
those are your stuff go slow don't put
money in things you don't understand
and always hire financial people with
the heart of a teacher
those are your three rules
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
chm is not health insurance but it is
christians helping other christians by
sharing each other's medical
bills the medical bill sharing from chm
was exactly the way the website
described it
there were no surprises no bait and
switch no hidden agenda
chm did everything they said they would
by sharing all of our eligible needs
we like that it's a non-profit ministry
and that we were being better stewards
of our money
all while helping other families
established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget that's chministries.org
backslash budget we absolutely believe
in it
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air his book
a bestseller already redefining anxiety
what it is
what it's not and how to get your life
back
it's an 84 page quick read
we're doing these books a few of them
here or there that are just a quick read
for you it's uh not um in other words
it's not a thick
book uh probably most people read it in
one evening
um particularly if you're concerned
about the subject
so redefining anxiety it's ten dollars
at daveramsey.com what it is
speaking of anxiety what it's not
and how to get your life back it is not
a death sentence
nope it's not a forever thing it's not
chronic pain no it's actually
a a good thing right whoa there's a
teaser
it's a good thing it lets us know things
are going on there's a teaser
so our last caller you and i and and a
bunch of you riding around your car
we're thinking about that one
going into the break dad passes away at
69
leaves 750 000 to mom plus a pension
plus a pension and um
paid for house and had done a really
good job
and um now his son
and mom are trying to figure out you
know how to invest and what to do
um that guy did a great job that's a
legacy yep
that's a legacy the first thing when
when we hung up the phone went to break
the first thought in my mind was i hope
i set my wife up like that
that's the goal right i know i'm not
going to be here
i hope that that's the conversation
they're having her and my son
yeah i mean you know what the
conversation normally is is how do we
pay for the funeral
dave i've sat with so many i can't even
count them
how many people i've sat with who have
lost their spouse
and they're looking at me in the eyes
and there's this particular look
and they say the words i don't know what
to do
and i'm sitting there it's the middle of
the night and
i i don't know what to tell you because
i don't know what i would do either
you know what i mean manufacture eight
thousand dollars for a funeral i don't
know where it's gonna come from wow
because
i yolo'd my wife my life away right you
only live once thank god it's friday oh
god it's monday
you can't take you with you and you
freaking child
you immature little brat you selfish
individual and you have absolutely no
legacy because of it none
i mean one definition of maturity is
learning to delay pleasure
live like no one else so later you can
live and give like no one else it
doesn't say you don't have a life
i have had a wonderful life i've done
anything i wanted to do and i've
completely set my family up
right those aren't mutually exclusive
they don't have to be
right it doesn't have to be the you know
i live in a cave click lint only come
out on triple coupon thursday
right i don't have a life at all and
that's the only way you build wealth
that is not how most people build wealth
most people build wealth while they're
having a good life
they just paid attention pay attention
and
there's this this consumer mentality for
kids especially
we got to buy our kids this buy our kids
that the new xbox just came out and it's
111
million dollars there's xbox some yeah
playstation whatever it is
can i tell you what happened last night
my wife said hey john
um our daughter josephine she's gonna be
five here next couple weeks
she just needs you and i know what that
means and so i
went and found josephine and said i
challenge you and her eyes got real big
and excited and she has made this
sword out of uh the inside of a
uh like a presence wrapper you know like
a wrapping paper oh they
are though yeah and we had a sword fight
for about an hour to where i'm so sore
oh they were broken it didn't she was
hitting and
what it was incredible then you find out
she put a broomstick inside it
yeah that's right beat her dad lost no
money
we had a great hour together bedtime was
much better this morning was better
and so you're talking about what's
legacy that we bought another
wittleyd box or we had some time to go
fishing and i put some money in
retirement i was able to save i was able
to do these things that when
not if but when it happens when i just
suddenly pass away
that my wife my son and my daughter are
saying how we can invest this money not
what are we gonna do
a godly man leaves an inheritance to his
children's children
proverbs says and
you know so it is a different
grieving process when there is a pile of
money there
money does not make them come back i
trade all the money just to have him
back i
understand you don't get to make that
trade these aren't trades you can make
so it's not an option that's not
it's not one or the other that's not how
this works it's just saying
money gives you margin you have room to
grieve
you cannot do enough crying
when you immediately have to go to work
to keep the lights on yep
i mean tomorrow morning you gotta go
work when your 65 year old mom has to go
find a job
tomorrow morning right after he died
yesterday that's right
because there's no money for the for the
light bill yep
i mean this is where people are this is
where a lot of people are dead
and and no one planned to be there
at all they didn't plan not to be there
i know that's exactly where i was going
the ones that aren't there planned to
not be there that's right that's exactly
right
i i just want people listening to this
as you're driving or mowing the yard or
walking around whatever you're doing
i'm telling you i've looked in the eyes
of countless people who have said the
words i don't know what to do and
don't let that be your family legacy and
what they really mean is is not only do
i not know how to process this grief
without this broken heart that i have
right now due to losing this person
but they're also saying i don't even
know how i'm going to bury them and how
to
him i don't know where their papers are
at their job
i don't know where our bills are because
we don't haven't communicated in 15 or
20 or 30 or 40 years
i just don't know what to do and that's
about having legacy conversations that's
about having a will that's about all
that stuff dave in the
it it distills down to one word
intentionality yep
just that one word be intentional dad in
the last
call is a hero he is a hero he did a
great job if i was going to coach him up
and you're him out there that is
listening you haven't died yet that
means you're listening right
i would add a couple things to his plan
okay
mom's clueless that's right he shouldn't
left mom clueless
mom and him should have been meeting
with the investment counselor
and saying here's what happens and let
me just tell you that's what sharon
ramsey does
she knows she's gonna the the the first
call
is gonna be to the smart investor pro
the second one will be the coroner
right i mean she knows exactly where her
bread is buttered right i make podcast
series out of these
situations dave you know that's really
what's gonna happen
yeah and um you know she is
uh not an investment professional i am
right
but she has enough understanding and she
knows exactly who to talk to
and so she doesn't have to have this oh
my god i have this money and i'm scared
by the money
right moment and so one thing you can
add to that last hero's
story is i'd like for him to have
trained mom
and had the counselor the coach the
advisor the smart vester pro in mom's
corner already
where they didn't call dave ramsey
didn't need me yep didn't didn't call dr
dolony because it didn't need you had
that
dialed in and just pick up a phone call
at smartvestor pro because
this is what we've talked about for the
last 10 years as we've been doing our
investing there
and we talked about mutual funds and we
talked about we don't do these and we do
do these and
here's how you pick a mutual fund and
the very basics
of investing where you have a basic
rudimentary understanding you don't have
to be an
mba in finance right and um
my wife was a full-time mom for 30
six years now you know so she's not an
investment professional
right uh she's very intelligent very
capable of understanding the concepts
and does
do have you had this conversation with
your kids oh yeah as well yeah
that's a great gift that my dad gave me
was sitting down saying
here's where stuff is here's where the
box is where all my stuff goes
um if something happens to me and sharon
together
they know exactly which drawer that's
right i've got the drawer at the house
we call it the legacy drawer it's where
everything is
every piece of paper every all the the
wheels the trusts
the uh legal documents on the properties
and we go over that once a year have a
little meeting with everybody
you know ours is a wee bit complicated
of course
but you know you can my family is this
simple all you got to do
is just say here's what to do and here's
how to do it and here's
and then that adds yet another level of
peace 750
000 adds a level of peace knowledge adds
another level of peace
that's what i want you people to do i
want you to love
your family well with being diligent in
these things
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dalone ramsey personality
author of the number of the best-selling
book redefining
anxiety what it is what it's not how to
get your life back
is my co-host today open phones a triple
eight eight two five
five two two five william is in
wilmington north carolina
hi william how are you i'm good
um i was i've been listening to you for
a little bit
and i'm uh i guess i'm the opposite i i
i felt um i felt like your last
little rant is probably me
unfortunately i just i uh
i make about 100k um
i just recently bought a house so i've
been rooting for like seven years or
eight years since the divorce
and i just i
have three boys and i i don't know where
to start to be honest with you
about somehow budgeting because it
always seems like i don't have
any money so
i don't know what i don't know where to
start
i'm not familiar with the program um
and it's a little overwhelming yeah
that's fair
that's fair how old are you man it's 49.
the subject money is so big and so
complicated
it's like the old african proverb how do
you eat an elephant
it's so big exactly you know where do i
start
and the answer is a bite at a time the
good news for you is
is that from 30 years of not only doing
this ourselves but teaching other people
to do it
we have a map through the bites
and what to do and we call them the baby
steps
and um and there's nuances and side
sidebars and rabbit holes you can go
down but
basically there's seven steps that
you'll go through between where you are
today and becoming very wealthy
and they're very clear and very easy to
understand that's good news
bad news is they're easy to understand
but they're hard to do because it's
about controlling the guy in your mirror
and uh i don't know about you uh william
but he's my problem
[Laughter]
he's mine if i can get that guy to
behave he can do a lot of stuff right
and be skinny and rich yes sir and so um
you know
that's the deal so that that's the thing
is personal finance is 80
behavior it's only 20 head knowledge so
i can walk you through the basics
the first thing i want you to do is i'm
going to put you into
ramsey plus for a year which includes
our class financial peace university
it includes ask a coach it includes a
tracker through the baby steps and it
includes
the world's best budgeting app called
every dollar
and that's where you're gonna start
you're gonna start with a budget
okay now budget is not a theory a
budget's not a theory it's the map to
the party
and if you don't follow the map to the
party you don't get to the party
right right so you can't make up your
own freaking map
you can't turn left on the wrong exit
and drive 100 100 miles you will not get
to the party
so you have to remember when you're a
little kid and you used to say you're
not the boss of me
yes sir you're the budget is not the
boss of you until you get it done
once you've designed it and told your
money what to do
then it's the boss of you it's gonna you
told it what to do and you built it now
you got to stick to it is the point
so all the budget is is every dollar
that's why we call the budgeting app
every dollar every dollar has an
assignment every dollar has a name
and when a hundred thousand dollars is
given a name an assignment
each time and you get to decide you can
decide i want to blow
50 000 of it you can do that but at
least you did it on purpose this time
you're not going to do that right but
you know at least you're doing something
on purpose
right now this is all happening to you i
want you to happen to it
so that's what the budget does and when
you lay out and you say this is my
take-home pay
and i've got two checks this month and
i'm gonna have this much money in my
account in this calendar month of
january 2021 and you lay that down on
paper and then you assign
every one of those dollars you are gonna
have two experiences number one you're
gonna feel like you got a raise
number two you're not gonna be able to
sit down for a week because you're to be
kicking your own butt on where that
money's been going all these years
right well the there's only the only
one thing about budgeting which i
is that i'm commission only so it
doesn't matter i don't even know
you do know you do know what january
looks like
no not yet do you get paid one day after
you make the sale
no sir it's um it's it's usually uh
two weeks after the sale okay then you
have a pretty bad gun good idea what
january is going to look like by the end
of december
we know what half of it's going to look
like and you also know what your
pipeline looks like
right so you're not going to be that far
off so you can still
still do it we'll show you how to do all
that i've i've grew up i've never had a
steady income
it's always been going on so
you once you got your budget going
you're making your money behave you're
going to feel like you got a raise then
the second thing is is we're going to
walk you up the baby steps
and that says any money i find in the
budget what do i do with it the first
thing is you're going to save a thousand
dollars the second thing is
we're going to list your debt smallest
largest and get you out of debt
everything but the house
third thing is we're going to build an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
and then once that's done then you're
going to go ahead and start putting 15
of your income away for retirement if
you are currently doing retirement
you're going to temporarily stop it
until you accomplish those first three
goals
and john there's such power and a clear
path there's always a power and a clear
path
and when you find yourself at 49 and
you're making good money
and you're coming off a divorce and you
got three little boys
that's when the the budget if following
that little
that path a series of little wins can
start to bring your whole life into
focus right
and you can start cleaning up a lot of
that as you said that mess that begins
in the mirror
yeah just by following a small plan
right william there's something
that happens when you say i could never
do this
i don't see a way there's zero energy in
that
it makes you tired when you say that
your voice kind of sounded tired
sounds sounds broken exhausted kind of
yeah like
hopeless right but then what happens is
when you can actually say gosh if i did
this and this
and then i'd be there and then i'd be
there and you start to see it
yeah and ho you start to see hope it's
yellow brick road each one lights up as
you walk right every time you take a
step
follow the alabama crowd yeah i mean
there you go man so i'm mayor munchkin
here dude i'm gonna walk you through
this right
and um you know that that's the
that is the exact way it works the
proverb says hope deferred
makes the heart sick but when desire
comes it's the tree of life there you go
and when you could see the finish line
you run a half i run a half marathon
when i want to run a half marathon
i can see the finish line after running
for two hours
yeah hour and 45 minutes i can see the
finish line you still have enough in
your tank to sprint
you take off that's right it's crazy and
how providential is
this this young man calls and got to be
on the on the line listening
to another son yeah yeah talk about my
70 year old father left us this yeah and
so dude you know you got this
30 years and you're the 20 years you're
that guys make it happen you're that guy
and you can be in a completely different
setting and you hold on we're going to
give you ramsey plus for a year
free as merry christmas and you go do
everything in that change your legacy
brother do everything that we say to do
don't change it don't fix the system
it's not broken
when we say do it you go do it and you
will have an incredible
experience and an incredible result baby
step one's a thousand dollars in the
bank
stop all investing until you get that
some people make a hundred thousand
dollars a year have never had a thousand
dollars in the bank
they don't even know what that feels
like it's all gone through every month
that's right it just goes straight
through just
in and back out only the names are
changed to protect the industry what's
the payments can i afford the payments
yeah it just goes straight through it's
just a cycle
right feel like a rat in a wheel and
i've had people tear up
to make 80 000 a year and go i can't
it's just so weird i feel so it's a
thousand dollars
why am i emotional because you've never
had control
yeah you've never it's always controlled
you you've never controlled it
and when they sit down and go okay i got
a thousand dollars now what well you
list your debts smallest to largest you
pay minimum payments on everything but
the little one you sell so much stuff
the kids think they're next
you get those stupid butt credit cards
out and you have plastic surgery tonight
you chop every one of them up and you
never again borrow money and bring those
three boys and let them watch you well
help to get them to help you cut the car
put them up let the legacy change today
let the transition start today light
some candles and candles and have a
ceremony that's right we're having a
plastic surgery party
tonight put an end to this crap
and get your life back this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsay
to get the best deal all right today's
question comes from
anthony in minnesota anthony writes
i've been saving money without my wife
knowing uh-oh
i've been taking more out of my paycheck
to put into my retirement account and i
also have been taking 65 dollars a
paycheck and putting it into an
online investing platform for another
savings account
i know this isn't right but i feel as if
it is the only way to save
i want to more aggressively pay down
debt but my wife thinks
debt is normal i can't convince her to
be more frugal and i know we should pay
off debt with this money
but i'm afraid that once i do that we
will just get back into debt
i'm lying to my wife to attempt to
provide and it hurts
what should i do stop lying
all right that's why you got two
doctoral degrees right there
stop lying
finding yourself in a challenge and
lying to get around that challenge takes
that challenge and sets it on fire
so the first thing you got to do is stop
lying
and so
i completely agree i mean and he's he
agrees yeah he knows he knows
he knows but so tell him what he should
do
man what he should do this is not a
tolerable situation no
and this is not a money situation this
is something that's deeper than this
if he thinks he's having to lie to
protect his wife if he's having to
go behind her back in multiple different
ways
um then they've got bigger challenges in
their marriage
and this this type of activity lets me
think that he thinks it's okay or not
okay but he
feels like he has to lie in other areas
and that she may be hiding stuff and so
at the end of the day
everybody's got to sit down and probably
at this point have a mediator
have a whether it's a marriage counselor
or a pastor or a friend that they trust
and him and his wife need to have a what
i would say a truth-telling session they
need to get somewhere where they can be
honest with one another
and do a clinical blood work on their
marriage
how are they doing are they doing okay
they're not doing okay they're not
but they need to put all cards on the
table how are we doing
and then they've got to move into i
can't continue to
be a part of a relationship where you
don't care about our future i can't be
in a relationship with you or you're
lying to me and hiding money from me
and everybody's got to come together and
they're not even ready to build the
future together because
the foundation of this thing is so
cracked
over the years when i've looked at been
in these situations
and someone sitting in my office not as
a
phd in counseling but as as just a guy
who's helping them with their money
i often find
that it's almost like i want to give
this guy
a syringe with red bull in it
because he
instead of being aggressive enough
in the relationship to cause a crisis
in the relationship have a fit
or you say have a duck fit right right
you know i mean just
flopping around on the floor create a
crisis be aggressive enough to go
dadgummit this is not okay right and you
don't have to be mean
or nasty but this idea that i'm
the passivity that has caused him to lie
as opposed to being aggressive and just
stand up in her face
and say no no more no
right and if you don't think yes then
we're gonna go see a marriage counselor
because no
we're not living like this we're not
gonna live broke to broke to broke and
in debt our whole lives
just because you wanna whine no
or you just wanna spend or whatever it
is right
you know he just will not face her down
and i
i just want to run down to walmart on
all four and pick him up a backbone
i said dude install it well the
challenge with the backbone is because
he's hiding out of cowardice
rather than courage but you have to have
an or what what happens
somehow he romanticized his
cowardice as if he's trying to take care
of his family with deception
right your romanticize oh i'm doing this
for the good of my family
because you're a wuss you gotta have
hard conversations
but you also have to have an or what
moment right so what if she says
if you choose to get that dead i'm out
this tells me anthony's just punting
that inevitable
situation that's going to blow up at
some point so have the coverage here's
the thing
she's not going to no she's not she
yearns for somebody to look her in the
eyes
and go we're going to do this and we're
we're going to win
we're going to do it today and we're
going to win right nobody
has ever made her believe that you can
win
and maybe just maybe it's her husband's
job in this case
not maybe for sure you know i mean i'm
being sarcastic
dude step up man up
woman up woman my husband i have to hide
from him because he's a little boy
and he wants to spend all his money on a
lunch room and i
you know i have to give him money he's
not he's not your son
he's your husband look him in the eye
and tell him to man up
no more right you know i saw there is
something about this kind of deception
that has a passivity to it
versus being proactive and aggressive
to actually get to the problem in the
relationship because the relationship's
the problem
not the money that's exactly right just
it's just a it's a red
flashing light saying danger will
robinson this thing's going down
right yeah gosh we're going to have to
go back and get lost in space clips
again because there's a whole generation
that does not know what the robot looks
like danger whale robin's danger
look at those hands dangerous
that's right you know and then he would
he'd always get unplugged that's right
every lost in space episode right but to
everyone out there
helping their marriage by hiding
or lying or stealing or cheating
you're not you're being a wuss you're
delaying cause you're not
facing reality you're in an effort
because you didn't have the courage to
cause a problem
you're causing a bigger problem that's
right in the nerd world they call it
one down where i instead of causing a
scene
on top i'm just gonna gently drag this
boat from underwater i'm gonna pull the
whole thing down
it's gonna take a long time and it's
it's the one down power move
i can't win up here i am not going to
head on up here
so i'm just going to gently be an anchor
and pull this whole thing down
slowly drowned us oh my gosh right
and that's what hiding and slipping
around the corners and
and got this account in that account man
you're gonna slowly drown i'd rather see
the thing go down in flames because you
went out swinging right yeah
yeah i put all the cards on the table i
brought a friend i brought a pastor i
bought a marriage counselor
this is what this is versus as for me
and my house
this is the way it's going to be the way
it's going to be you know and you do you
know
the interesting thing is is that
people who are struggling with hope who
don't believe that it can that you can
win
when you declare with courage that we're
going to do what it takes to win
they are so thankful for that and it's
it's when your teenager doesn't believe
that they can make it
right and you declare with courage we're
gonna do whatever it takes by god for
you to learn to
do this that's right leadership we're
gonna we're gonna get tutors
uh we're gonna we're gonna work until
midnight i'm gonna stay up with you
we're gonna have calluses on our hands
and on our brain we're getting this crap
done that's right
and you're gonna win and you are not
going down in flames on my watch you're
going to turn the electronics off you're
going to stop
acting you're going to stop why right
it's not just affirmative you got to
stop you've got to change your life too
right we're going to do the thing what
it takes for
us to win what has to be true we're
going to make a list of those things
we're going to turn off that turn on
that that's right and we're
gonna and that that kid who is
depressed and hopeless and looking down
and and rebellious and everything else
is just gonna go
thank god somebody can't let cares me
enough to bust me in the mouth
metaphorically and cause this to happen
and that's
man i've seen that in leadership inside
these walls in this business
i've seen that in families i've seen it
everywhere else you have to have the
courage to cause a scene
which in my head is you gotta turn the
lights on right yeah my friend my friend
seth godin says cause a ruckus cause a
ruckus i was a ruckus no more
you know and do it in the marketplace go
make a ruckus in the marketplace
that's good stuff very good stuff stop
lying anthony
yeah that's it right
calls a ruckus a lot of a lot of
education to say stop lying because
those are ruckus love it so that you
don't have to lie anymore
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero live from the headquarters
of ramsey solutions
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studios it's the dave ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight
eight two five five two two five my
co-host today here on the air
dr john deloney ramsey personality and
author of the best-selling book
redefining anxiety
uh kind of a timely topic for the
dumpster fire year of 2020 that's
finally coming to a close
so we're here to talk about your mental
health we're here to talk about the
crazy people in your freaking family uh
whatever help you need along those lines
uh he has
the answers for you and we'll talk about
your money as well
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five glenn is in rapid city south dakota
hi glenn how are you
i'm hi i'm good dave thanks you guys
taking the call and thank you for your
ministry
thank you um yeah i wanted to tell you
guys first thank you so much my wife and
i are 100 on board and baby step two
in the first 59 days we paid off uh 15
000
and yesterday i paid off another 22
thousand dollars by paying off my
getting her in my truck wow that a boy
and you are getting it man
yeah i just found out that my hooptie
has heated mirrors i'm sitting in it
right now
heated mirrors that is by definition not
a hoopty glenn
i didn't realize it spent 3 500 bucks on
it
boy that's high class that's high class
south dakota driving right now
right um well i'm a small business owner
a heating and chlorine electrical
contractor um and the problem i have
with budgeting i
i can't i'm having a tough time with it
because i never know what goes on the
top line
i i can't plan far enough ahead because
i never know from day to day i do
all service work and so it just it
changes so much and i just
can't get my head around it um
okay let's stop let's stop uh talking
about it as a personal budget for a
minute and let's just talk about it as a
business
how long have you been doing the
business six years
okay so uh
you do service work on heating and air
yeah and electrical too yes okay the
people that i know in the business tell
me that the first
cold snap is a big time
because people turn their heat on for
that been off all summer and they turn
it on it doesn't work
and the first and the first warm day
or warm week they turn their ac on it
doesn't work
so those are usually two big months am i
right
you're right you're absolutely right
okay so we can start to predict some
things
you a you have seasonality and b you
have six years of records
and so what i would do is say i'm going
to look at if you're
if you're coming up on march i'm going
to look at my last three marches
and see what the pattern is and they
ought to inform me as to what this march
looks like
so let me give you an example uh
what would be a normal month for you in
top line
just any pick a month give me a number
50 000 you do 50 000 a month
in gross sales and it's just me
okay i'm in the wrong business glenn
yeah all right so
50 000 a month top in gross sales okay
so if you looked at last march
and it was 40 000 and then march before
that and it was 30 000
and the march before that and it was 25
000 you would see a growth
trend year over year
same month last year not last month
same month last year so we're seeing a
25 to a 30 to a 40 to a 50
trend all in the last three or four
marches
which tells me if i'm coming up on this
march i might be looking at 60.
you see how i did that yeah i do now
that's not accurate because we don't
know
for sure but we're forecasting based on
history same
month last year same month
last several years gives me a trend line
that i can use now if you made 50 every
single march
for the last three marches then we could
probably predict
50 not 60.
yes okay because the trend line is flat
but we still have some old data to use
to forecast with and predict with and so
now could you do 52 yeah could you do 45
yeah the likelihood of you doing 30 is
almost zero as long as you work every
day
right sure and the likelihood of you
doing 90 is almost zero
true you're going to be some range plus
or minus
off of that trend line from the last
several years same
month last year so that's how you do
business
forecasting on your top line now your
bottom line is going to be a function of
your top line because you probably run a
pretty standard margin on that 50.
you probably know on every time i make
50 000 i net x
and you're just going to have that x to
work with that's what you're going to
take home and use
but you're not going to vary unless
something happens
okay now something could happen you
could hire a guy
and that would increase that's a change
in those
over those trend lines but you just say
okay what's my trend line
and what's different this year well i
mean pandemic could be different
that could be that could be what's
different off the trend line so i really
can't predict the
the trend line to be that way i'm
probably gonna i'm gonna
predict it to be less or more
if you're in a plexiglass business you
predict more
[Laughter]
you know the bleach business the toilet
paper business you'd predict
more i should have gone into plexiglas i
should have should have done that early
in my life but yeah so
that's that's how you do your
predictions there you uh
same month last year and you can look at
last month
and that's somewhat of a prediction but
it could be
that you know we've got businesses here
inside of ramsey
that uh like ed solutions
our high school curriculum a lot of the
decisions are made in april
for the whole year and so we have this
huge
mountaintop experience on our p l's
on the gross revenues april april's the
month that's when the heart that's when
the crop comes in
right you're a farmer when you're going
to harvest your crop right and you know
other than that you're planting and
making nothing
right and you're waiting on the fall
crop to come in then you're gonna you
know you're gonna pull the cotton you're
gonna pull the
corn you're gonna pull the soybeans
whatever it is right and you're gonna
you know you know when that's coming we
know we're gonna take that to market we
don't know exactly what it's gonna yield
but we know it's not gonna happen in
this month we know it's gonna happen in
that month
so several callers today across all the
shows today dave have
been a small business owner i'm a
salesman and there's this
this common theme of it's hard for me to
predict
i can't i don't know how to how to guess
i'm concerned just as an outside guy
that there's
there's people running businesses
without keeping any sort of
tracking data without asking themselves
what a year over year
do i know what i'm making in this month
what what did i make last year and this
month how can i make more
how do we help folks pay better
attention to their data
entree leadership yeah go start listing
the entrepreneurship podcast get online
and join the
entre leadership elite and we'll teach
you how to run your business
because most small businesses fail
because they don't do what we're talking
about
they don't predict they don't do any
budgeting they all they do is look at
their p l they drive the car looking
only at the rear view mirror what
happened
a year ago not what's going to happen
next year it's almost like halfway
getting christmas shows up every year on
the same day right
yeah christmas this year who knew it was
gonna be in december this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com
will help you every step of the way just
like they've helped
thousands of my listeners with free
design help
by phone and online plus they guarantee
the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you feel like you should have made
more progress on your debt by now
i understand when it comes to paying off
debt sometimes it feels like all grind
and no
reward here's the thing when you try to
do it on your own
you're more likely to fall back into bad
habits that's why when
ish happens you stop making progress
and that's why you need ramsey plus
ramsey plus is our step-by-step money
plan that will give you the
accountability
the encouragement the practical tips
that you need to pay off your debt
faster than you can do on your own
when you have someone in your corner
cheering you on
you make the tough choices that get you
where you want to be
ramsey plus helps you go from ish to
all in so you can finally
keep more of your money to start your
free trial of ramsey plus just text the
word
trial to 33 789
a free trial by testing
or texting trial two
three three seven eight
nine open phones at triple eight eight
two five five
two two five dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host
today jen is with us in orange county
california hi
jen welcome to the show how can we help
hi uh mr ramsay and dr jaloni thank you
so much for taking my call
sure um mima has me my husband have a
live household money question for you
um we have a couple different options
for me potentially starting to work
part-time that we're considering and
we wanted to get your opinion if we've
considered all of our options and what
is the best way to maybe test those
options
we are on baby steps four five and six
and we're both working right now
um and we love our careers but more
recently i just felt a tug to want to be
at home more
we have two kids a five-year-old and a
two-year-old
and we've also realized that how much
work there is for managing a house and
the cooking and the laundry and
appointments
and so the the two options we're really
looking at is
is me going part-time when the
five-year-old goes to school next fall
and we can still pay off the house in in
a little less than 15 years if we do
that
the other option we're looking at
because we really want
the freedom and getting the house paid
off is is to suck it up for like three
years
and pay off the house um because then i
wouldn't really have
um have to have the option to work maybe
um but that would mean maybe doing more
of a baby step
3b forage and bringing the retirement
down to maybe the company match
so those are the two options we're
considering what do you make
um together we make no no no what do you
make
165. you make 165.
what does he make about 135.
what does he do um he's in finance for a
local restaurant company
and how old are you guys we're 37.
okay what do you do i'm
work for medical device company
regulatory
and you can do that part-time um
i think i have options even if the
company i don't
i work at currently wouldn't be willing
to do it i think i i know enough people
in industry
um or could potentially consult if if
that company or another company wouldn't
wouldn't hire me but i'm
okay so if you went part-time how much
does it cut your all's income
you're from 165 to what one about 80.
so about in half yeah okay
if i'm in your shoes i'm going part-time
in september when the five-year-old goes
to school
okay the way i decided that was this is
not a question
of financial well-being
this is just a question of how fast you
get rich
yeah you cannot have those years back
yeah i'll trade i'll trade getting rich
a little slower for you to be there with
the five-year-old when she comes home
making her cookies
or whatever the scenario is you want to
do yeah
yeah that's quality of life hard to hear
that okay
it's quality of life well the thing is
you you get tremendous satisfaction and
you're tremendously good at your job you
don't hate your job
no no no you're a professional woman i
mean you are you're killing it
and so you're really trading something
that you
love for something that you love more
and jen you need to know and like i'm
telling you like you don't know this
there is an entire industry there's an
entire cultural ethos
that is against women having peace
period so if you are at work
crushing it at 165 you and your husband
are just
sailing through life there is a part of
that culture that's going to
tug on you and say why aren't you at
home they're going to shame you for not
being home
yeah and you're going to yeah and then
you're going to take
you're going to take a a half pay cut
still making double the average u.s
salary
you're going to go home and there's
going to be an industry telling you
seriously what kind of what kind of
modern woman are you you walked away
from that career what's wrong with you
you're just going you hate your family
financially
so there's a [ __ ] out there somewhere
to shame you no matter what you do right
and so here's what you have to do as you
make this transition and i'm speaking
from somebody we've made the same
transition in our
my house okay you've got to get a couple
of people around you that are going to
be able to walk alongside you as you
make this transition you're going to
have to learn new skills
and most of us don't think i have to
learn skills on how to run a household i
can just quote unquote take care of my
kids
it's more complex than that you got to
learn some new things and you got to
have people around you that you can
reach out to and say
today sucks and i love my kids but i
don't like them today
and that aren't going to judge you and
say you're the worst mom and we're going
to send you mean cards and pray for you
but they're going to laugh and send you
funny memes and you're going to go on
with your day
and then there's going to be people who
are going to pick you up on the work
side of it
and and and but you gotta have folks who
walk alongside you i just
dave i know too many folks who go home
to follow this call to be at home with
their kids
and then it just is a silent vortex
there and they get lonely and they start
doubting and then they start looking
online and then everybody's telling them
what a loser they are and they made the
wrong decision
and it's hard you gotta have people walk
alongside you when you do this this is
this is when you learn that facebook
friends are not
you're not your friends no no
they're not real they're not they're not
real friends
they're not oh my gosh yeah
jen go home go home and it's going to be
hard
and use it use that wonderful brain that
god gave you to be a world-class mom
while you're doing consulting or
whatever it is you
and here's the other thing you've done
all of your projections
as if your income is linear and his
income is linear and it's not you're
both in professional careers both of you
are going to see your incomes go up even
if you're working part-time
and he's continuing to so it's not a
15-year versus a three-year
it's a three-year versus a eight or ten
year yeah
you're gonna get there good for you
really really good question
really good question mike's in
philadelphia hi mike welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hey dave hey john how are you guys doing
great what's up
i had a quick question just generally
around motivation uh my wife and i we
had our kind of never again moment about
two years ago
um had around two hundred fifty thousand
dollars in student loan debt plus a
mortgage
good luck and she had been lost yeah she
had lost her job and she was about 60
of her income uh so we then kind of made
the decision
um you know we gotta buckle down and we
just we said we gotta pay off the debt
when she
gets back into it we really paid off a
really a lot of debt over the past
two years even with us doing a lot of
work but just having generally just
trouble with motivation
um especially with the holiday season
you know we want to spend some money on
our kids and
a few other things and just just trying
to join a little bit of advice
you evil guy want to spend money on your
kids what's wrong with it
of course you need to spend some money
on your kids yeah and of course you've
lost uh you're not having as much
progress as you thought you were going
to have because you lost her income
those are realities man that's not a
loss of motivation that's a loss of
mathematics
that's okay yeah yeah you're not proud
of your pain it's good
no no and it's i mean luckily she gets
you to get a new job and like i said
yeah she'll get a new job and then
you're going to get it you know you're
going you're going to be able to plow
again because you got
you got you got a tractor again you know
i mean you get moving again but right
now you're kind of slow
and that's just kind of your reality it
didn't mean you quit and it doesn't mean
you lost your motivation it means you
lost your income that's right when
you're running a marathon sometimes you
stop and you get
that water station right and you slow
down a little bit you get the water
you're not losing your desire to finish
you got to slow down for a minute and
then you're going to pick back up and
then you're going to start running again
yeah it's nutrition
and you know what you're facing is
exactly the way you should be feeling
you're going to do great get your kid a
christmas gift amen
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease
christian healthcare ministries
or chm is not health insurance
but rather a federally approved
exemption to the healthcare law
it's a time-tested model to help take
care of your health care costs
it's christians helping other christians
by sharing each other's medical bills
adjusting to a new system of paying for
health care
was kind of tricky but that's where chm
stepped in
and they really helped navigate that
water
with the hospital and the payment want
to see if chm is the right fit for your
healthcare needs
check out our website at
chministries.org backslash budget
that's chministries.org backslash
budget it was just such a relief to know
that financial burden was going to be
taken care of
[Music]
if there's one thing 2020's taught us
about investing it's you cannot invest
alone you need someone in your life who
knows the market
better than you do and teaches you
so that you make smart decisions and
they talk you off the ledge
look i love do-it-yourselfers but diy
investors do not have the same rates of
return
that those of us who have pros in our
corner
i don't pull my own teeth and i don't do
my own investing
i get advice just like i tell you to do
you invest in the wrong things you get
caught up in trends you make rookie
mistakes
you build a portfolio based on what you
read on reddit
oh my god what were you reading reddit
for that's a lost a day
you'll never get that time back not
realizing it all it takes is one
freaking pandemic to knock you
completely off track trust me you do not
need to add any unnecessary stress to
your life
stop winging it
a good investment pro like a smart
investor pro will help you follow the
right
plan for your money so you understand
what's going on and you invest in the
right things and you never have to worry
if you're making the right
decision if this is your never again
moment for your retirement and your
investing
don't be at the mercy of some global
crisis ever again text
invest to 33 789
text invest to 33789
and you can create a rock solid
investment plan starting today bethany
is with us in
scranton pennsylvania hi bethany welcome
to the show how can we help
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure
um i have a question so my husband and i
have three very small kids
and our middle child has down syndrome
so we are just wondering what you would
advise for
the future um we recognize that college
may be a possibility but it may not be
um so we're just wondering if what you
would do
different um just say for her future and
then would you save the same monetary
amount
per kid
um no equal is not fair and fair is not
equal
right okay and so if this child needs
more money set aside than the other
two then uh to take care of them then
that's there's nothing wrong with that
at all
matter of fact that would be called
being a good parent
and so you're not you don't have some
moral obligation to dole out
everything equally um
the uh uh so you know
uh what we're gonna do is you're just
gonna save the money in your name
okay and you're gonna have life
insurance
on you and your husband okay and in both
cases the life insurance beneficiary is
going to be named
to the family trust that is formed upon
your death
okay you need to get a lawyer and get a
will built or go to mama bear legal
forms and get a will built it depends on
how complicated your estate is but yours
is getting ready to get pretty
complicated
so what you normally do for a special
needs child there's a special needs
trust
which lasts their entire life and the
trustee is in charge of investing the
money
and handling the money to take care of
the child
okay and they do it according to your
directions and so if this were my child
i would have a special needs trust
that's formed upon my death
and my wife's death and it's funded with
the money from the life insurance policy
this the beneficiary on the life
insurance policy says x
number of dollars out of this policy
goes into special needs trust
okay and i'm going to put it across four
types of mutual funds growth growth in
income aggressive growth and
international and the income
produced off of this fund is to take
care of this child and that is the
trustee's job
uh you would also name a guardian to the
extent that the child as an adult
is not able or is able to take care of
themselves
might be it might be a sibling
okay okay something like that now it
with
children that are not special needs and
they're minors we always build a family
trust
and the same exact thing the life
insurance proceeds go into the trust
upon your death if both of you die
okay and or your mutual funds and
investments that you already have go
into
that trust in the event that both of you
die and it works exactly the same way
the only difference is that when the
child reaches a certain age that the
money's just released to them because
they're adults and they're on their own
and you don't need a trust you know a
family
a childhood trust surviving to that kid
65
with special needs you may right
it's the only difference is the length
of time the thing survives they work
exactly the same way
so if you put 500 000 in there and the
thing makes ten percent that gives fifty
thousand dollars a year to take care of
that kid
right that's simple okay
and you can put the 500 000 in there
with investments over time
but until you have that 500 000 you
would have
500 000 worth of your life insurance
allocated to that
and i just made that number up but just
i would just say
take 10 and use that as your number it's
probably not right but it's close enough
okay and and say you know all right i
want them to have
three thousand dollars a month well
that's thirty six thousand dollars a
year so that's 360
000 so let's just call that a 400 000
policy
okay and i'm gonna get a million dollars
on your husband and you
and if something happens to you 400 000
is going into special needs
kids trust and the other 600 000 is
going over here
for the other two 300 each and they've
got very similar
wording and so forth okay
makes sense it does i think so yeah
it's um so how severe is the downs
well i mean we don't know she's two oh
we have a long time to go so she's only
two um how old are your other kids
my oldest is four and i have a
two-year-old and a one-year-old
wow oh you are in it aren't you yeah
yes and you're calling me about a well
yeah
oh my goodness yeah so well yeah i mean
even just to set aside for college
yeah like it feels i don't know what to
do for her i would not set aside for
college i would just keep it in your
name
okay because you can control it that way
and you can do with
what you want if you put it into their
name you might lose control of it when
they turn
21 the courts might take it and take it
over to manage it for the kid
and it's not their money it's your money
yeah
okay and you're not going to do anything
that's not for the benefit of the kid
no no we just i we know for us
everything's a little bit slow
financially we're not um we're just yeah
so you'll get there yeah you're gonna
get there because you're thinking about
it and you're being intentional
all right brian's in birmingham hey
brian welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave and john thanks taking my call
sure
oh birmingham uk i thought it was
alabama okay
no no a bit further away in the uk
obviously
just a little bit the things a little
bit different here to to the u.s and
a lot of the things that i've i look at
youtube videos blogs that sort of thing
a lot of things say that kind of the
baby steps and your plan don't apply to
the uk but i tend to disagree
for the last sort of year i've gone down
a rabbit hole of the connect your videos
and
um followed your steps thus far and it
served me pretty well
um i've got out of depth and uh where
i'm
where my wife and i at the moment that's
where baby steps four five and six
the concern that i have um i'm 31
my wife is she's 28. um
prior to looking at your videos i didn't
really know anything about finance at
all when i just list
paycheck to paycheck um my concern now
is whether i'm gonna have enough
uh in retirement um i'm we're saving 15
of our total gross income um why
wouldn't you have enough punching
numbers into
i don't know because i keep punching
numbers into the compound what are you
what are you investing it in
uh index funds for 100 index yeah
and what's the rate what's the rate of
return in the last 30 years on those
index funds
well the index fund i'm at the moment
it's only been announced
every year so far you save 15 of your
income
from 32 to 62 at nine percent you're
getting plenty of money
and just so in case people don't know
math works the same in any country
don't owe people money it works wherever
you live
it's a cool thing about math it's
international the baby steps work
exactly the same in the uk as they do in
the us with the exception of what you
put your money into
right in baby step four because
obviously you have a different
retirement system
but he's got access to a nine percent
rate of return fund
you're going to be just fine saving 15
of your income for 30 years this is the
dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
our scripture today first thessalonians
5 16-18
rejoice always pray without ceasing give
thanks in all circumstances for this is
the will of god in christ jesus for you
william james says it is our attitude at
the beginning of a difficult task which
more than anything else will affect its
successful
outcome
that is that's worth doing again i'm
gonna do that one again
william james which if you've never read
by the way might be one of the founders
of the positive thinking movement just
way back in the ralph waldo emerson
era it is our attitude at the
beginning of a difficult task which more
than
anything else will affect
its successful outcome
it turns out your attitude is probably
more important than your skill
your intellect your education
that's true i mean i'm making i'm just
adding on to mr william james here but
you know it really does matter well
they've done all those
since this this quote comes out they've
done years and years of
you know mindset and um
we were just talking about do you what
type of mindset are you bringing to this
is it a restrictive one do you think is
it
is it a scarcity mindset is an abundance
mindset is it
uh how you enter in i think i'm gonna
fail you're gonna fail
right i think i'm gonna approach this as
a challenge
i'm the kind of person who overcomes
challenges you're gonna lean in you're
going to lean in you're not going to
know what you're doing and then all of a
sudden that attitude that you take to it
is going to help you be successful in
the back end what if you approached a
hard conversation with your wife
as i'm the kind of husband that has hard
conversations because i value my
marriage
versus oh here we go again right you
don't think that doesn't affect that
conversation
yeah i'm the kind of guy that to go back
to deal with her
i'm the kind of guy that's gonna leave
my family when i suddenly die
which i will i'm gonna leave that plan
to be suddenly
i hope so man i'm hoping so you're
planning suddenly
well the way you live i don't want to be
sudden but i am going to
be the kind of guy who leaves them in
that kind of situation versus well i'm
just going to avoid it yeah you know
i love that quote man that's good your
attitude at the beginning of a difficult
task
is the largest indicator he is saying
of whether or not you succeed it is not
your skill level
it's not your intellect
it's the way it's your outlook man i got
a lot
of that'll preach right there all right
kyle is with us in columbus ohio hey
kyle what's up
hey guys how are you doing better than
we deserve how can we help
hey so uh i just wanted to get your
advice uh
what a situation um my my wife and i
um are on baby step two uh we love you
guys we're kind of new
the last couple months we're on baby
step two and my wife will be graduating
in the spring um with her uh master's
degree
um right now our household income is
about um 113 000
and her salary stands to double once
she's graduated grad school
so my question um and that will put your
income at what
uh about 163 thousand what's she getting
her master's soon
so it's a it's an advanced health care
degree right now it's a new degree but
it's equivalent to like a nurse
practitioner or a
physician's assistant um basically
she'll be able to function like a
pulmonary fellow
um and yeah it's absolutely amazing
um so my question is we've had some
issues in the past with my um
mother-in-law specifically as i've heard
you say she probably is kind of a travel
agent for guilt trips
and to where she and
my sisters-in-laws have reached out to
my wife for
financial help in the past for certain
things
so my question with that is kind of as
my wife is approaching this
this point in on in our life in our
marriage
and in her career where she will be
making more money how do i
help support her um moving forward
when i i know in the back of my mind
my in-laws will probably just be asking
for more
and more as she makes more money in her
career
does she want to give them that money um
she wants to help them but she doesn't
want to enable them
um she she's she's been burned in the
past
um to the point where now i'm concerned
for
her emotional and mental health she's so
she's been so bad
she's had two panic attacks in the past
yeah so she
she has in the past but in the the last
year or so
um she's made the decision to um
basically
cut them off unless it's you know an
absolute
emergency here's the thing um
my daughters were teenagers we spent a
lot of time discussing
uh premarital sex
because if you wait until you're he the
moment to decide about that
you're going to lose the decision and so
you have to decide ahead of time
and steal your mind s-t-e-e-l
your mind to be ready for
an an inevitable conflict
and you have to have already decided
before the conflict occurs what's going
to happen
and you have to build up the courage and
the muscle
in your brain to be ready for that and
so
i i think that's what you're asking and
i think that's what you've got to do and
it may involve seeing a counselor it may
involve you you guys sitting down with
your pastor
and releasing her from her
felt obligation to these people to where
she really gets
very comfortable with no okay
i don't know john yeah and the challenge
you're going to have is you're going to
want to
do that no for her and until she won't
work until she comes to
comes to terms with her ability to tell
her family no
um you're just gonna have to play a
supporting role there you can as we
talked about earlier you can cause a
ruckus man you can say yeah i don't want
using our money
it's hurting them but that's this is her
family and this is a
brilliant woman your wife she's getting
a master's degree
in the healthcare field she's not
lacking an intellect
apply that intellect to growing
walking you walking with her have her
apply that intellect to growing
in this area of emotional strength
and she loves her pulmonary patients
enough to say stop
smoking don't go run after you just had
this she needs to love her family in
that same way
and say no right
yeah yeah absolutely and it's very
difficult the most difficult boundary
setting
is between a daughter and a mother a
daughter and her sister
female to female is the most difficult
guys can look at each other and go
screw you no a lot easier
it's a lot easier for us right yeah i
mean we just
because we're just combative but for
ladies it's like the emotional
relational thing is like oh my god you
know i heard their feelings and it's
like
you know but she's gonna reach a point
where she's going to end the
relationship
completely if she doesn't deal with this
in strength
ahead of time now and she it's going to
get nasty
the earlier she can draw boundaries the
better
yeah and just tell her to get ready for
the next time but go ahead and start
working on it
spend some you know like you study you
know get i'm going to send you
a copy of uh dr lonely's book redefining
anxiety i'm also going to send you a
copy of dr henry cloud's book
boundaries and this is her homework
she's got to get ready for because what
happens is
the when you set a boundary with someone
who doesn't have boundaries
100 percent of the time they come at you
they want to know if that boundary's
going to hold right
well they feel entitled to you right
they feel entitled to a chunk of your
butt
and they keep chewing on your butt until
you don't have one
and they will chew your after they shoot
your butt off they'll chew your soul out
from under you yep that's exactly what
happens
you're gonna let your family starve you
hate your mother
what's wrong after all i've done for you
you're just gonna let your sister she
just needs all i've done this is your
own
flesh and blood i don't know what we did
you oh
oh because you're fancy now you got your
masters and your fans oh
yeah you've done you done going up above
your raisins
you don't know you don't you forgot
where you came from
no i didn't and that's why i'm not there
that's right i don't forget a bit of it
kyle you're a good man stand by that
woman yeah i'd help her
help her get those muscles built that
puts us out of the dave ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it
in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
[Music]
jesus
[Music]
so
[Music]
you